No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks Copilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs and help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work.
没有人是为了看电子表格而去找汉克的，他们是为了吃一顿美味的披萨。不过最近店里却很冷清。于是汉克决定重新推出1美元的披萨切片。他请微软Excel中的Copilot查看他的销售额和成本，并帮他看看自己能否承受得起。Copilot向汉克展示了资金的去向，以及是哪些小配料让1美元披萨得以实现。
Now, Hank has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365Copilot.com slash work. For centuries, people have used music to soothe and to heal, but it's only in recent decades that scientists have begun to study and understand how music affects our minds and our bodies. Armed with new research tools, scientists have been learning more about how our brains process music and exploring how music can be used to improve health and well-being in areas
现在，汉克店门口排起了长队。汉克负责做披萨，Copilot负责处理电子表格。访问 M365Copilot.com slash work 了解更多信息。几个世纪以来，人们一直用音乐来舒缓身心和进行治愈，但直到最近几十年，科学家们才开始研究和理解音乐是如何影响我们的心灵和身体的。借助新的研究工具，科学家们对我们的大脑如何处理音乐有了更多的了解，并探索如何将音乐用于改善以下领域的健康和福祉：
as diverse as chronic pain, Parkinson's disease, and stroke recovery. Today we're going to talk about this latest research in the field with a world-renowned musician who has become a leading proponent of research on the connection between music, the arts, and health, and a scientist who studies the cognition and evolutionary origins of music. Some of the questions we hope to tackle are, did humans evolve to be an inherently musical species? How can understanding the evolutionary origins of music help us develop more effective music therapies? What are some of the music therapies being used today, what are the biggest challenges remaining in the field? And what is the most promising research direction for the future? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of
比如慢性病、帕金森病和中风康复，这些领域各不相同。今天，我们将与一位世界知名的音乐家（她已成为音乐、艺术与健康之间联系的研究的主要倡导者）以及一位研究音乐认知和进化起源的科学家一起探讨该领域的最新研究成果。我们希望探讨的一些问题包括：人类是否进化成了一个天生具有音乐天赋的物种？理解音乐的进化起源如何帮助我们开发更有效的音乐疗法？当今正在使用哪些音乐疗法，该领域面临的最大挑战是什么？以及未来最有希望的研究方向是什么？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是由
the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. As I said, we have two guests today. The first will need no introduction for music lovers. Soprano Renee Fleming is one of the most celebrated musicians of our time, sometimes called People's Diva. She's performed on the world's leading opera stages and concert halls and appeared with all the major orchestras of Europe and North America. Among her many awards are the National Medal of the Arts and Five Grammys. In recent years, she's become a leading advocate for research on the science of music and how the arts can be used in health and healing. As artistic advisor to the John F. Kennedy Center for the Performing Arts, she leads the
美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）出品的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。如我所说，我们今天有两位嘉宾。第一位嘉宾对于音乐爱好者来说无需介绍。女高音歌唱家雷妮·弗莱明（Renee Fleming）是我们时代最受赞誉的音乐家之一，有时被称为“人民的迪瓦”（People's Diva）。她在世界主要的歌剧舞台和音乐厅演出过，并与欧洲和北美的所有主要交响乐团合作过。在她的众多奖项中，包括国家艺术勋章（National Medal of the Arts）和五项格莱美奖。近年来，她已成为音乐科学以及如何将艺术用于健康和治愈的研究的主要倡导者。作为约翰·F·肯尼迪表演艺术中心（John F. Kennedy Center for the Performing Arts）的艺术顾问，她领导了
Sound Health Initiative in partnership with the National Institutes of Health and the National Endowment for the Arts. She's given presentations with scientists and practitioners around the world and is editor of a new book called Music and Mind, harnessing the arts for health and wellness, which includes contributions from eminent scientists, musicians, and other artists on the intersection of science, health, music, and arts. My second guest is one of the contributors to this book. Dr. Anurutz Patel is a professor of psychology at Tufts University where he researches the cognitive, neural, and evolutionary foundations of musicality. Most recently, he's been studying how other animals process music as a window into how
声音健康倡议（Sound Health Initiative），该倡议与美国国立卫生研究院（National Institutes of Health）和国家艺术基金会（National Endowment for the Arts）合作。她与世界各地的科学家和实践者共同进行过演讲，并且是一本名为《音乐与心灵：驾驭艺术以获得健康与福祉》（Music and Mind, harnessing the arts for health and wellness）的新书的编辑，该书收录了杰出科学家、音乐家和其他艺术家关于科学、健康、音乐和艺术交叉领域的撰稿。我的第二位嘉宾是本书的撰稿人之一。阿努鲁茨·帕特尔博士（Dr. Anurutz Patel）是塔夫茨大学（Tufts University）的心理学教授，他在那里研究音乐性的认知、神经和进化基础。最近，他一直在研究其他动物是如何处理音乐的，以此作为了解
human musicality evolved. He's author of the 2008 book Music, Language, and the Brain, which won the ASCAPDEMS Taylor Award and is working on a new book about the evolution of human musicality to be published by Princeton University Press. Thank you both for joining me. Thank you. Thank you. Now, Renee, if I may call you by your first name.
人类音乐性如何进化的一扇窗户。他是2008年出版的书籍《音乐、语言与大脑》（Music, Language, and the Brain）的作者，该书荣获了美国作曲家、作家与出版商协会（ASCAP）德姆斯·泰勒奖（Taylor Award），目前正致力于撰写一本关于人类音乐性进化的新书，将由普林斯顿大学出版社（Princeton University Press）出版。感谢二位加入我的节目。谢谢。谢谢。那么，雷妮，如果我可以直呼你的名。
Yes, please. Let's start with you. How did you first become interested in the connection between music and health and the brain? What led you to do this work and put this book together? Well, I had performing anxiety that manifested in unusual ways. And one of them was pain. So pain was a distraction from the performance anxiety, from the pressure of performance. I was not an innate or natural performer at all.
好的，请吧。让我们从你开始。你最初是如何对音乐、健康和大脑之间的联系产生兴趣的？是什么促成了你开展这项工作并把这本书汇编在一起的？嗯，我曾有过表现焦虑，它以不寻常的方式表现出来。其中之一就是疼痛。所以疼痛其实是对表现焦虑、对表演压力的一种转移。我一点也不是一个天生或自然的表演者。
I love music and I loved studying music and being in a practice room, but I wasn't kind of a gregarious outgoing kid. And so in trying to figure that out, I did a lot of reading on the mind-body connection. Dr. Sona was, his work was very helpful to me. And along the way, I discovered that researchers were studying music. And when I met Dr. Francis Collins at a dinner party in 2015, I asked him why. And because I had just been appointed advisor to the Kennedy Center, I said, do you think the NIH and the Kennedy Center could work together to provide a platform for science with the public?
我热爱音乐，我喜欢研究音乐并在练习室里待着，但我并不是那种热情外向的孩子。因此，为了弄清楚这一点，我大量阅读了关于身心联系的书籍。索纳博士（Dr. Sona）的工作对我有很大帮助。在这个过程中，我发现研究人员正在研究音乐。2015年，当我在一次晚宴上遇到弗朗西斯·柯林斯博士（Dr. Francis Collins）时，我问他为什么。而且因为我刚刚被任命为肯尼迪中心的顾问，我说，你认为美国国立卫生研究院和肯尼迪中心能否合作，为公众的科学研究提供一个平台？
Because I think the public would be as interested as I am in the work that's happening at this intersection of health and art. And he said yes, and we've been passionately sharing this information ever since. Dr. Patel, is it okay if I call you, Annie? Please. Your chapter of the book is called Are We an Inherently Musical Species? Can you talk about what it means to be an inherently musical species and why this is an important question to ask? So this is one of the big questions about human nature that's unresolved and were there major thinkers on taking opposite viewpoints.
因为我认为公众会和我一样对健康与艺术交叉领域正在进行的工作感兴趣。他说可以，从那以后，我们就一直充满热情地分享这些信息。帕特尔博士，请问我叫你安妮可以吗？请便。你在书中的那一章叫做《我们是天生具有音乐天赋的物种吗？》（Are We an Inherently Musical Species?）你能谈谈成为一个天生具有音乐天赋的物种意味着什么，以及为什么这是一个重要的问题吗？这是一个关于人类天性的重大且尚未解决的问题，主要的思想家们对此持有截然相反的观点。
So Charles Darwin in his book on Human Evolution about 150 years ago, argue that we are inherently musical. We are musical today because our ancestors evolved. Musical behavior, which had some functional value for our ancestors, and that laid the foundation for our musicality today. William James, his contemporary, very much disagreed, and he loved music. He loved Darwin. But he thought music was a purely cultural invention, something that we were fortunate to figure out how to do and enriches human life, but not something we specifically evolved to do. And perhaps I can give you an analogy to help clarify the difference. Neuroscientists today. completely agree that we evolved to speak and use language. Our brains have specialized circuits for
查尔斯·达尔文（Charles Darwin）大约在150年前在他关于人类进化的书中辩称，我们天生具有音乐天赋。我们今天之所以有音乐天赋，是因为我们的祖先进化出了音乐行为，这对我们的祖先具有某种功能价值，这为我们今天的音乐天赋奠定了基础。他的同代人威廉·詹姆斯（William James）非常不同意这一点，但他很热爱音乐。他很喜欢达尔文。但他认为音乐纯粹是一种文化发明，是我们侥幸摸索出来、能够丰富人类生活的东西，而不是我们为了它专门进化而来的东西。也许我可以给你一个类比来帮助阐明两者的区别。今天的神经科学家
that, an ability that is part of our human nature. We have to learn it. Babies have to learn how to speak, but we have predisposed to learn that skill by evolutionary biology. They also agree that we didn't evolve to read and write. Reading and writing is a purely cultural invention, takes advantage of the fact that we have language, so we have good visual perception and good attention and good motor control. We put all those things together to create written language, which is a hugely important part of our life. Nobody would dispute that language writing is enormously valuable to our society and our culture. And so it's not a question about the value of music.
完全赞同我们进化出了说话和使用语言的能力。我们的大脑为此拥有专门的电路，这种能力是我们人类天性的一部分。我们必须学会它。婴儿必须学会如何说话，但我们通过进化生物学对学习这项技能具有内在倾向。他们也一致认为，我们并没有进化出阅读和书写能力。阅读和书写纯粹是一种文化发明，它利用了我们拥有语言这一事实，因此我们拥有良好的视觉感知、良好的注意力和良好的运动控制。我们将所有这些东西结合在一起创造了书面语言，这是我们生活中极其重要的一部分。没有人会否认语言书写对我们的社会和文化具有巨大的价值。因此，这并不是一个关于音乐价值的问题。
If music is a purely cultural invention like writing, it could still be very valuable for health, for culture, for social reasons, but not something we specifically evolved to do. So I think it's an important question because it's unresolved and also because we're finally at a turning point where after 150 years, we might be able to start to answer this question with some. science using data from fields like brain imaging, genetics, studies of other species, studies of child development, studies of cross-cultural studies and so forth. And so it's exciting time to be
如果音乐像书写一样纯粹是一种文化发明，它仍然对健康、文化、社会原因非常有价值，但它并不是我们专门进化来做的事情。所以我认为这是一个重要的问题，因为它尚未解决，也因为我们终于迎来了一个转折点，在经历了150年之后，我们或许可以开始用一些科学来回答这个问题，这些科学使用了来自脑成像、遗传学、其他物种研究、儿童发展研究、跨文化研究等领域的数据。所以这是一个令人兴奋的时刻，
studying this question. To follow up, your recent research has tried to answer the question about musicality by looking at musicality in other species, including dogs and parrots. What can we learn about music and humans by studying other animals? One thing we can learn is, to some extent, We don't have a time machine. We can't go back and figure out how music began in our species. So what comparative biologists do, evolutionary biologists, we look at other species to get clues. So, for example, take beat, our sense of beat in music, which is something we see all over the world. Every culture has some form of music with a beat.
来研究这个问题。接下来，你最近的研究试图通过观察其他物种（包括狗和鹦鹉）的音乐性来回答关于音乐性的问题。通过研究其他动物，我们能了解关于音乐和人类的什么信息？我们可以了解的一点是，在某种程度上，我们没有时间机器。我们无法回到过去，去弄清楚音乐在我们这个物种中是如何开始的。所以比较生物学家、进化生物学家所做的是，我们观察其他动物来寻找线索。例如，以节拍为例，我们在音乐中对节拍的感觉，这是我们在世界各地都能看到的现象。每一种文化都有某种带有节拍的音乐形式。
Often people use it for dancing and so forth. And children learn how to move to a beat and synchronize their movements to a beat without any special instruction. They pick it up from watching others and socializing and so forth. And for many people, this is the most primal aspect of music. And they think, okay, if there's one aspect of music that we might share with other animals, it's going to be beat and our sense of beat and our ability to move to the beat. Well, actually, it turns out that our closest living relatives, apes and monkeys don't seem to have a sense of beat like we do.
人们经常用它来跳舞等等。孩子们在没有任何特殊指导的情况下，学会了如何随着节拍移动，并将他们的动作与节拍同步。他们通过观察他人、社交等方式习得这一点。对很多人来说，这是音乐中最原始的方面。他们会想，好吧，如果说音乐有一个方面是我们可能与其他动物共享的，那就是节拍、我们对节拍的感觉以及我们随着节拍移动的能力。嗯，事实上，事实证明，我们现存最近的亲属，类人猿和猴子，似乎并不像我们那样具有节拍感。
They don't seem to synchronize to beats spontaneously when they hear beat-based rhythms, when you try to train them. Monkeys do it very differently. A fundamental aspect of how we deal with beat is we predict the beat. When you perceive a beat, you automatically start to predict when the next beat is coming very accurately, and that's how you can clap right on time or dance right on time with a beat. If you try to train a monkey to tap to a beat, they wait for the beat, and then they react. They don't predict, and it takes a lot of special training to get them to predict.
当他们听到基于节拍的节奏时，或者当你试图训练他们时，他们似乎不会自发地与节拍同步。猴子的做法截然不同。我们处理节拍的一个基本方面是，我们预测节拍。当你感知到一个节拍时，你会自动开始非常准确地预测下一个节拍什么时候到来，这就是为什么你能踏着节拍准确地鼓掌或跳舞。如果你试图训练一只猴子随着节拍敲击，它们会等待节拍，然后做出反应。它们不进行预测，而且需要大量的专门训练才能让它们学会预测。
So their brains just deal with beat in a very different way. So why do we have this ability that seems so simple and yet is not shared with our close living relatives? It's usually biological things that are simple are shared, like the way your kidney works, or I'm not saying the kidney is simple. but things that, you know, there's a lot of shared biology between us and our close cousins and shared things like visual perception abilities. I theorized at one point that maybe there's something about only certain kinds of animal brains can acquire this ability spontaneously to move to a beat.
所以它们的大脑处理节拍的方式截然不同。那么，为什么我们拥有这种看起来如此简单却又没有与我们现存近亲共享的能力呢？通常，生物学上简单的事情是共享的，就像你的肾脏工作的方式一样，或者我不是说肾脏很简单，但是你知道，我们和我们的近亲之间有很多共享的生物学特性，还有像视觉感知能力这样共享的东西。我曾一度推论，也许只有某种特定动物的大脑才能获得这种自发随着节拍移动的能力。
And those are brains that have the ability to learn complex sounds, what's called complex vocal learning. Listening and imitating sounds is how you acquire your sound repertoire. And that's a rare ability. We're the only primate with that ability. Dogs don't have it, cats don't have it. The vast majority of animals don't have it. But there's a group of animals, three groups of birds that have it,
而那些大脑具有学习复杂声音的能力，也就是所谓的复杂声乐学习能力。聆听和模仿声音是你获取声音库的方式。这是一种罕见的能力。我们是唯一拥有这种能力的灵长类动物。狗没有，猫也没有。绝大多数动物都没有。但是有一群动物，有三类鸟类拥有它，
songbirds, hummingbirds, and parrots. And we showed that, so I hypothesized that maybe this ability helped lay the foundation for beat synchronization. And then we showed that actually a parrot could actually spontaneously move to the beat of music and keep the beat at different tempi and that was replicated by another group. And so now it looks like they're the only other species besides humans that do this spontaneously, which gives us some clues
鸣禽、蜂鸟和鹦鹉。我们证明了，所以我假设这种能力可能为节拍同步奠定了基础。然后我们证明了实际上鹦鹉可以自发地随着音乐的节拍移动，并保持不同节奏的节拍，这被另一个研究小组复制了。所以现在看来，它们是除了人类之外唯一自发做到这一点的其他物种，这给我们提供了一些线索，
about the origin of this ability in our own evolution. It seems like perhaps the ability to imitate complex sounds was one of the foundations from which beat synchronization emerged. So it's kind of a way of going back in time and thinking about what were the precursors to this ability in our own evolution without having a time machine. I want to talk more about animals at some point. But right now, Renee, I want to ask you, many chapters of the book are by practitioners and researchers looking at different music and creative arts interventions for the purposes of treating various mental and physical health issues. what are some of the well-supported music interventions that people are using today? I would say the strongest areas of research have supported what we call melodic intonation therapy, which takes advantage of the plasticity of the brain, to transfer speech from Broca's
关于这种能力在我们自身进化中的起源。似乎模仿复杂声音的能力可能是节拍同步从中涌现的基础之一。所以在没有时间机器的情况下，这有点像回到过去，思考在我们自身的进化中这种能力的先决条件是什么。我想在某个时候更多地谈论动物。但现在，雷妮，我想问你，书中的许多章节都是由实践者和研究人员撰写的，他们着眼于不同的音乐和创意艺术干预措施，以治疗各种身心健康问题。人们今天正在使用的、有充分支持的音乐干预措施有哪些？我想说，最强有力的研究领域支持了我们所谓的旋律语调疗法（melodic intonation therapy），它利用大脑的可塑性，将语言从布洛卡区
area to the singing area of the brain, which is on the other side of the brain, the opposite side of the brain. But it's also, frankly, musical activities are in every known mapped area the brain. It's why it's so complex. It's why hearing, but especially engaging with music, playing an instrument, et cetera, singing, you know, as well because you're using language and in your finding pitches. So by hearing, so these are all so complex that this particular intervention enables people who have suffered a stroke or traumatic brain injury to speak again, sometimes after one session with music therapist by singing. So singing enables them to kind of recapture the words that they were trying to communicate.
转移到大脑的唱歌区，该区域在大脑的另一侧，即大脑的对侧。但坦率地说，音乐活动也存在于大脑中每一个已知的映射区域。这就是为什么它如此复杂。这也是为什么聆听，尤其是参与音乐、演奏乐器等，唱歌，你知道，也是因为你在使用语言并且在寻找音高。因此，通过聆听，所有这些都如此复杂，以至于这种特殊的干预措施使那些遭受中风或创伤性脑损伤的人能够再次说话，有时在与音乐治疗师一起进行一次课程后就能通过唱歌再次说话。因此，唱歌使他们能够重新捕捉他们试图传达的词汇。
So that's one area. Movement disorders are the other hugely strong area of research that's been supported. And that's for Parkinson's, for MS, for people who have difficulty moving. And again, taking advantage of plasticity of the brain to stop the freezing and the shuffling and enable people to move more fluidly and gracefully. And in fact, recent study actually, we found this in December, discovered that even just imagining a song, imagining the beat of a song, like when the saints go marching in,
所以这是一个领域。运动障碍是另一个获得支持的、研究极其强劲的领域。这是针对帕金森病、多发性硬化症（MS）、有运动困难的人。同样，利用大脑的可塑性来停止僵直和小碎步，使人们能够更流畅、更优雅地移动。事实上，最近的一项研究，我们在12月份发现了这一点，发现甚至只是想象一首歌，想象一首歌的节拍，比如《当圣徒行进时》（When the Saints Go Marching In），
can enable somebody who's having those difficulties to walk fluidly across the street and feel safe. I've been using it to exercise because it keeps my tempo up. And I can even carry on a conversation and hear something in the background in my mind's ear. And then there are some other. Certainly, memory is powerful for Alzheimer's. The memory is, music memory is the last memory to go in a patient with dementia in many cases.
就能让一个有这些困难的人流畅地走过街道并感到安全。我一直在用它来锻炼，因为它可以保持我的节奏。我甚至可以进行对话，并且在脑海中听到背景中的声音。然后还有一些其他的。当然，对于阿尔茨海默病来说，记忆力是非常强大的。在许多情况下，痴呆症患者最后消失的记忆是音乐记忆。
And so scientists are studying that like crazy to try and figure out where it comes from. And I'm sure Annie knows more about all of these things than I do, but I find it just so fascinating. Pain is another powerful area of study that's not only is it working, but it's being legalized, consistently. I mean, I had a friend who had a brain breed, I believe, recently, and just terrible. She was an excruciating pain. She couldn't look at screens. She couldn't do it. No activities, dark room, all of that. And I said you could listen to music. And she discovered by chance that only Jimmy Hendricks, as loud as she could play it, would offer any relief to her. And the minute the volume went down or the music turned off, the pain came flooding back. So for obvious reasons, our opioid epidemic,
因此，科学家们正在疯狂地研究它，试图弄清楚它来自哪里。我确信安妮对所有这些事情的了解比我多，但我发现它太迷人了。疼痛是另一个强有力的研究领域，它不仅有效，而且正在不断地被合法化。我的意思是，我有一个朋友最近脑动脉瘤发作，我相信是这样的，简直太糟糕了。她痛不欲生。她不能看屏幕。她做不到。没有活动，黑房间，所有这一切。我说你可以听音乐。她偶然发现，只有把吉米·亨德里克斯（Jimmy Hendrix）的音乐开到最大声，才能给她带来任何缓解。而只要音量一调小或音乐一关掉，疼痛就会再次汹涌而至。出于显而易见的原因，我们的阿片类药物危机，
especially this is a strong area of research. Any, anything you would add to that? Any other areas? Yes, so there's also music in stroke recovery. I was just at the Neurosciences and Music Conference in Finland. There's now a conference dedicated to this field since going about every three years since about 2000. And there's some wonderful work being done there
尤其是这是一个强有力的研究领域。安妮，有什么你要补充的吗？还有其他领域吗？是的，还有音乐在中风康复中的应用。我刚在芬兰参加了神经科学与音乐会议。自2000年左右以来，大约每三年举行一次，现在有一个专门致力于该领域的会议。那里正在进行一些精彩的工作，
on actual randomized control trials comparing music listening to audiobook listening to no additional therapy. with patients that have had all the standards post-stroke therapies to look at cognitive and neural recovery, and they're finding benefits of music listening, self-selected music listening on both cognition and emotion recovery from stroke. And the neat thing about this group is they're also doing brain imaging to look at the underlying mechanisms.
关于实际的随机对照试验，将听音乐与听有声读物与不进行额外治疗进行比较。对象是接受过所有标准中风后治疗的患者，以观察认知和神经恢复情况，他们发现听音乐（自主选择的听音乐）对中风后的认知和情绪恢复都有益处。这个小组妙的地方在于，他们还在做脑成像来观察潜在的机制。
And this is what's neat. I think that Renee can certainly speak to this is, we're at this exciting time where the clinical work is kind of beginning to dovetail with the basic science work and understanding what's going on in the brain. who it works for, who it doesn't work for as well and why. And that's really an amazing step forward. That's amazing. That's very exciting about stroke. I do know that stroke choirs are phenomenal for people.
这就是妙处所在。我认为雷妮绝对可以谈谈这一点：我们正处于这样一个令人兴奋的时刻，临床工作开始与基础科学工作完美结合，去理解大脑中正在发生的事情。它对谁有效，对谁无效以及为什么无效。这真的是一个惊人的前。太棒了。这关于中风的研究非常令人兴奋。我确实知道中风合唱团对人们来说是非凡的。
Yes, yes, that's right. And both for social reasons, because a lot of what happens with neurological damage is isolation. Like the dance for Parkinson's that was started by the Mark Morris Group and David Leventhal, who has a wonderful chapter in your book, Renee. There's a fantastic film about it called Capturing Grace, and they show it's not just the music and what it does for movement. It's bringing people together and breaking that isolation that is so powerful for neurological patients. So is music more therapeutic if you create it, participate in it, or if you merely listen to it?
是的，是的，没错。无论是出于社交原因，因为神经损伤发生时往往伴随着孤立。就像由马克·莫里斯舞团（Mark Morris Group）和大卫·莱文塔尔（David Leventhal）发起的帕金森舞蹈一样，你在书中有一个精彩的章节，雷妮。有一部关于它的精彩电影叫《捕捉优雅》（Capturing Grace），他们展示的不仅仅是音乐以及它对运动的作用。它把人们聚在一起，打破了那种对神经系统患者来说如此强有力的孤立。那么，如果你创造音乐、参与音乐，或者如果你仅仅聆听音乐，音乐是否更具治疗效果？
Do we know, is there a difference? Well, engaging with music is certainly very powerful. It utilizes so many more skills. For childhood development, there have been wonderful studies. That's another strong area of research showing that there are lasting changes in the brain after just two years of studying a musical instrument. And the same group at USC has just started now to study singers. So choir singing for children.
我们知道吗，这其中有区别吗？嗯，参与音乐当然是非常强大的。它利用了更多的技能。对于儿童发展，已经有很好的研究。这是另一个强有力的研究领域，表明仅仅学习两年乐器后，大脑就会发生持久的改变。南加州大学（USC）的同一个小组刚刚开始研究歌手。也就是儿童唱诗班唱歌。
And so I'm very anxiously awaiting the results of that study. But go ahead, Any, I'm sure you have other responses as well. Oh, no, I think that's right. And I think listening and actively singing or playing music can both be. beneficial depends on the circumstances. So for example, for pain management, there's exciting work happening with music. And as Renee touched on how it can help with pain. And Yoko Brat, who has a chapter in the book, has been doing interesting research on that. I think she's in Philadelphia. And their music listening can be quite effective, like Renee's story with the Jimmy Hendricks.
所以我非常急切地等待这项研究的结果。但请说，安妮，我相信你也有其他的回应。哦，不，我认为那是对的。而且我认为聆听以及积极地唱歌或演奏音乐都可以是有益的，这取决于具体情况。例如，对于疼痛管理，音乐正在进行令人兴奋的工作。正如雷妮所触及的那样，它如何帮助缓解疼痛。书中有个章节的作者约科·布拉特（Yoko Brat）一直在对此进行有趣的研究。我想她在费城。那里的听音乐可以非常有效，就像雷妮关于吉米·亨德里克斯的故事一样。
But in other cases, especially if you're looking at how musical engagement can change and improve brain function in other areas like speech. There it looks like active participation, singing, playing an instrument is important for making those plastic changes that are lasting and benefiting other cognitive functions. Have you ever rearranged your furniture and discovered the carpet underneath looks brand new while the rest of it looks, well, not so new? It's time for a carpet upgrade. At the Home Depot, we have stylish choices at simple prices from all the top brands. Best of all, we can install it for you, starting at only 49 cents per square foot. So all you have to do is pick your perfect floor.
但在其他情况下，特别是如果你在研究音乐参与如何改变和改善其他领域的脑功能（如言语）。在那里，看起来积极参与、唱歌、演奏音乐对于产生持久并有益于其他认知功能的那些可塑性改变是很重要的。你有没有重新摆放过家具，却发现底下的地毯看起来像是崭新的，而其余部分看起来……嗯，没那么新了？是时候升级地毯了。在家得宝（The Home Depot），我们以简单的价格提供来自各大顶级品牌的时尚选择。最棒的是，我们可以为你安装，每平方英尺仅需49美分起。所以你所需要做的就是挑选你完美的地板。
Start your carpet project today at the Home Depot. How doers get more done. Exclusions apply for licenses. See home depoteper.com slash license numbers. So given what we already know about music's effect on our health and well-being, what are the prospects for music therapy to become a standard health care practice? I mean, do you foresee insurers covering it beyond what they're doing right now? And Renee, I want to ask, is this something that you're actively working toward?
今天就在家得宝开始你的地毯项目吧。实干家成就更多。许可排除条款适用，请参见 homedepot.com/license-numbers。鉴于我们已经了解的音乐对我们的健康和福祉的影响，音乐疗法成为标准医疗实践的前景如何？我的意思是，你预计保险公司会将其报销范围扩大到目前所做的之外吗？雷妮，我想问，这是你正在积极努力的方向吗？
Yeah, there are 12 states that now have licensure for music therapists. We need all of the states to bring this into view. Texas is working on it right now. It is a total bipartisan effort because everybody cares about health care and they also care about health and wellness. We have a mental health crisis that's around the world. I'm also an ambassador to the World Health Organization and Dr. Tegras said he's incredibly concerned. that depression is up by 30% around the world. So that's another wonderful statistic from a study is that 45 minutes of engagement with any kind
是的，现在有12个州对音乐治疗师进行许可。我们需要所有的州都把这一点纳入视野。得克萨斯州目前正在努力。这是一项完全跨党派的努力，因为每个人都关心医疗保健，他们也关心健康和福祉。我们正面临着一场世界范围内的心理健康危机。我也是世界卫生组织（World Health Organization）的大使，特德罗斯博士（Dr. Tegras）表示他极其担忧，
of art activity and especially listening to music can reduce anxiety by 25%. It's just a brief amount of time. So it makes sense, you know, but you have to have the science that supports it. So I'm working hard to create a stronger pipeline for research. I have Investigator Awards. We just offered our first seven and we'll double them next year. And I'm working with the Aspen Institute of the neural arts blueprint on this. But it's taking a postdoc student who has access to a lab, who was working with an artist or is an artist.
抑郁症在全球范围内上升了30%。所以这是来自一项研究的另一个精彩统计数据：进行45分钟任何形式的艺术活动，尤其是听音乐，可以将焦虑减少25%。这只是很短的一段时间。所以这是有道理的，你知道的，但你必须有支持它的科学。所以我正在努力为研究建立更强大的渠道。我有研究员奖。我们刚刚提供了前七个，明年我们将把数量翻倍。我正在为此与阿斯彭研究所（Aspen Institute）的神经艺术蓝图合作。但这意味着要招收一名能够进入实验室、与艺术家合作或是其本身就是艺术家的博士后学生。
And the panel who chose the winners is incredibly highly esteemed scientific panel and academic panel. And then the NIH is following up with fellowships. So they're working on that now, which we'll hope to have them this year. So I'm hoping that we can get at least 10 fellowships around the country. So we need support for that. That needs financial support. It's a public-private partnership. And then I would love to art care to succeed,
评选获奖者的评审团是一个声誉极高的科学评审团和学术评审团。然后美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）正在跟进奖学金。所以他们现在正在努力，我们希望今年能争取到。因此，我希望我们能在全国获得至少10个奖学金。所以我们需要对此的支持。这需要财政支持。这是一个公私合作伙伴关系。然后我希望艺术关怀能够取得成功，
which would be allowing people to connect to existing arts and health initiatives in the areas where they live, because I know personally that most performing arts venues, offer all kinds of initiatives for children with special needs or caregivers and the people that they take care of and et cetera. Even the Musique Fadine in Vienna, the hallowed hall of the Vienna Philharmonic now has a caregiver's initiative. And that news went around the world because, you know, the fact that all of the performing arts are saying, hey, we have something to offer you that can improve your health and well-being and take care of those of you who are more
这将允许人们与他们居住地区的现有艺术和健康倡议建立联系，因为我个人知道，大多数表演艺术场所都为有特殊需求的儿童、照顾者以及他们所照顾的人等提供各种倡议。甚至维也纳金色大厅（Musique Fadine），即维也纳爱乐乐团（Vienna Philharmonic）的神圣大厅，现在也有了一个照顾者倡议。这个消息传遍了全世界，你知道的，因为所有表演艺术都在说，嘿，我们有一些东西可以提供给你，能够改善你的健康和福祉，并照顾你们当中更脆弱的人。
fragile. So I have a lot of hope. Now, we need policy changes as well. We really need. But ultimately, the goal is to have art embedded in health care altogether. It's low-cost. It's not pharmaceutical and it's not, it's not invasive. Every children's hospital should already have this in just a creative art studio. It helps reduce some pain medication and and it makes everybody much more comfortable. So we're working towards it, but it's baby steps. It's all just beginning. The fact that the NIH has spent $40 million funding research is a huge validation for the
所以我有很多希望。现在，我们需要政策改变。我们真的很需要。但归根结底，目标是将艺术完全嵌入到医疗保健中。它的成本低。它不是药物，而且它不是侵入性的。每家儿童医院都应该已经在创意艺术工作室里具备了这一点。它有助于减少一些止痛药的使用，并使每个人都感到更加舒适。所以我们正在为此努力，但这只是婴儿学步。这一切才刚刚开始。美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）花费4000万美元资助研究这一事实，对罗马人（领域内的人）的工作是一个巨大的肯定。
work for people in Rome. And they're going to keep spending, you know, integrative medicine. Everybody understands how important it is now. So I think we'll get there. Let's talk for a minute about music education. Again, given what we know about how music affects brain development, and can improve learning in other areas. Should music be a requirement in all schools?
他们将继续支出，你知道的，整合医学。每个人现在都理解它是多么重要。所以我想我们会达到的。让我们花一分钟谈谈音乐教育。同样，鉴于我们了解音乐如何影响大脑发育，并且可以改善其他领域的学习。音乐应该成为所有学校的必修课吗？
Why isn't it? So the arts should be in our schools altogether. I mean, for so many different reasons. I mean, I was at Chicago Lyric Opera as an advisor before this, and we put the arts back in elementary schools there in the city through volunteers, teacher volunteers. And superintendents actually quickly realized how beneficial it was. and they started paying for it.
为什么不是呢？所以艺术应该完全进入我们的学校。我的意思是，出于许多不同的原因。我的意思是，在此之前，我在芝加哥抒情歌剧院（Chicago Lyric Opera）担任顾问，我们通过志愿者、教师志愿者，将艺术重新带回了那里的城市小学。而校长们实际上很快意识到了它是多么有益，
So for one thing, and even in later age students, they discovered, I talked to somebody who was the president of the Board of Education there who said, truancy is one of the biggest problems we have in the country right now. I know in D.C. it's a huge problem, and it's contributing to teen violence and all manner of mental health issues. And to have young people engage in something they love, it gives them a sense of themselves. is important.
并且他们开始为之付费。例如，甚至在年龄较大的学生中，他们发现，我跟那里教育委员会的一位主席交谈过，他说，逃学是我们国家目前最大的问题之一。我知道在华盛顿特区这是一个巨大的问题，它助长了青少年暴力和各种心理健康问题。让年轻人参与他们热爱的事情，能给他们一种自我认同感，
Bessel Finder Coulke's book, The Body Keeps the Score, which has been on the bestseller list for a couple of years now. I was really stunned when I read his chapter about, you know, things that work and how theater, being involved in theater, saved his son, he feels. So there's no question that the art should be in schools. I've been trying to encourage Los Angeles and California to use some of the money that's the money that they have now for arts education to add creative arts therapists alongside arts educators.
这是很重要的。贝塞尔·范德·柯克（Bessel Van der Kolk）的书《身体会记住一切》（The Body Keeps the Score），已经连续几年登上畅销书排行榜。当我读到他关于有效的方法以及参与戏剧如何拯救了他的儿子（他觉得）的那一章时，我真的很震惊。所以毫无疑问，艺术应该进入学校。我一直在鼓励洛杉矶和加利福尼亚利用他们现在拥有的用于艺术教育的一些资金，在艺术教育工作者旁边增加创意艺术治疗师。
Because on both fronts throughout the country, we don't have enough. We don't have enough teachers anymore who teach the arts because kids said, hey, you know what? They're kind of from school, so I'm going to do something else. And they certainly don't have enough creative arts therapists around the country. So this is an area that I'm encouraging young artists to think about. That's wonderful. In fact, I could just add something in Renee's book.
因为在全国各地的这两个方面，我们都不足。我们不再有足够的教授艺术的老师，因为孩子们会说，嘿，你知道吗？它们有点像学校里的附属品，所以我要去做别的。而且他们在全国各地绝对没有足够的创意艺术治疗师。所以这是我鼓励年轻艺术家考虑的一个领域。这太棒了。事实上，我可以在雷妮的书里补充一点，
music in mind, there's a wonderful chapter about state-of-the-art national statistics on music in America's schools by Kenneth Elpis, which lays out just how much how we need more music in schools. And it's very uneven, which schools have it and which don't, or arts in general. And then there's several chapters about stories about like Renee was talking about how arts basically saved somebody from dropping out and brought them into the school and made them passionate about learning through the arts and then kept them there. And things like truancy is so interesting because you wouldn't think that that wouldn't be
《音乐与心灵》（Music in Mind）中有一个精彩的章节，关于肯尼斯·埃尔皮斯（Kenneth Elpis）撰写的关于美国学校中音乐的国家统计数据的最新现状，其中列出了学校中多么需要更多音乐。而且情况非常不均衡，哪些学校有，哪些学校没有，或者总体上哪些学校有艺术。然后还有几个章节讲述了一些故事，就像雷妮所谈论的那样，艺术基本上如何拯救了某人免于辍学，将他们带回学校，使他们对通过艺术学习充满热情，然后把他们留在了那里。像逃学这样的事情非常有趣，因为你不会认为那会是
the first thing I would think of is why we need arts in the schools. But I think it makes a lot of sense. You need reasons for people to want to be in school. And the arts are potentially a huge draw for people that otherwise feel sort of alienated. So the book is incredibly wide ranging with contributions from scientists, musicians like Roseanne Cash, even novelist Anne Patchett, playwright Anandt Veer Smith. Renee, how did you get all of these people to contribute? Well, I started, of course, with everybody that I know from the science side of things,
我们为什么需要在学校里引入艺术的第一个想法。但我认为这很有道理。你需要理由让人想要呆在学校里。而对于那些原本感到有些被疏离的人来说，艺术可能是一个巨大的吸引力。所以这本书内容极其广泛，汇集了科学家、音乐家（如罗珊·卡什，Rosanne Cash）、甚至是小说家安·帕切特（Ann Patchett）、剧作家阿南德·维尔·史密斯（Anand Veer Smith）的撰稿。雷妮，你是如何让所有这些人进行撰稿的？嗯，我当然从我认识的科学界的所有人开始，
from the research side of things, and the institutions, really, to have, I didn't know anything about the NIH. I do nothing. So when I walked in that day to listen to scientists, present, including Annie, and some music therapist as well, I was stunned. And so I tried to kind of help the public who probably doesn't know anything either, know more about it. So this was kind of an idea of like a snapshot of the field as it is right now. In fact, Susan McSammon, who wrote your brain on art that was a bestseller last year, said, it's not a, it's not a, we're trying to grow a field, but she said it's actually a movement.
从研究界和各机构开始，真正地，我对美国国立卫生研究院一无所知。我什么都不知道。所以当我那天走进去听科学家（包括安妮）以及一些音乐治疗师做报告时，我惊呆了。所以我试图帮助可能也一无所知的公众了解更多。所以这有点像对当前该领域现状的一个快照。事实上，去年成为畅销书的《你的大脑与艺术》（Your Brain on Art）的作者苏珊·麦克萨蒙（Susan McSammon）说，这不是一个，这不是一个……我们试图发展一个领域，但她说这实际上是一场运动。
These people are very excited about this. And there's a whole grassroots understanding and desire and the part of normal people to bring the arts into their own lives, just to make it, to doodle or to do whatever it is that you enjoy. I'm a poster child this year. I knew it's a rough time in our history. And I said, I have to get off the news feed. And so I'm outside in nature and I'm reading one novel after another, and I'm going to concerts and plays, and I do something every single day. And I cannot tell you how much. I highly recommend it. Now, Renee, you've subjected yourself to some of this research as well. I mean, can you talk about your experience of singing in an MRI, the machine itself?
这些人对此非常兴奋。普通人中存在着一种自下而上的理解和愿望，他们希望将艺术融入自己的生活，哪怕只是为了涂鸦或做任何你喜欢的事情。今年我是个典型的反面教材。我知道这是我们历史上艰难的一段时期。我说，我必须脱离新闻推送。所以我走到自然界中，一本接一本阅读小说，我去听音乐会和戏剧，我每天都在做一些事情。我无法告诉你这是多么棒。我强烈推荐它。现在，雷妮，你也让自己参与了其中的一些研究。我的意思是，你能谈谈你在核磁共振（MRI）机器里唱歌的体验吗？
Yes, yes. It's so funny because I came up with a good joke, which is, you know, people are afraid of the MRI. They, you know, terrifies them. And I said, well, have you ever flown economy? You know, because it really, you know, it's very similar. and you at least get to lay down. So it was an experiment that was devised by a team at the NIH. It had me singing, speaking, and imagining singing. And they were very surprised by the outcome because imagining singing was by far the most powerful,
是的，是的。这太搞笑了，因为我想出了一个好笑的笑话，那就是，你知道的，人们害怕核磁共振。他们，你知道的，这吓坏了他们。我说，好吧，你坐过经济舱吗？你知道，因为真的，你知道，这非常相似，而且你至少还能躺着。所以这是由美国国立卫生研究院的一个团队设计的一个实验。它让我唱歌、说话和想象唱歌。他们对结果感到非常惊讶，因为想象唱歌是迄今为止最强大的，
and had a much stronger effect on my brain than the other two. And after the fact, they said, well, you're a singer, so singing is easy for you and second nature. I said, that's true. Whereas imagining singing had me tuning out the noise and it had required a different level of focus, et cetera. So, yeah, I got to be a guinea pig in an experiment and understand a little bit about how this whole research field works.
并且对我的大脑产生了比其他两项强得多的影响。事后，他们说，好吧，你是一位歌手，所以唱歌对你来说很容易，是第二本能。我说，那是真的。而想象唱歌则需要我屏蔽噪音，并且需要不同水平的专注力，等等。所以，是的，我成了一个实验中的小白鼠，对整个研究领域的工作原理有了些许了解。
I want to go back to talking about animals again, if that's okay, Annie. I'm just wondering, you know, a lot of animals make noise, but we don't call it music. For example, some people say the noise that whales make is singing. So the bigger question is, I mean, you talked about, beat as being intrinsic? Is that the only thing? I mean, how do we define music? How do we know it when we hear it? Oh my gosh, that is a thorny question because music as a cultural product just keeps changing. I mean, you think of Arnold Schenberg's music when it was first premiered. There were people
我想再次回到关于动物的话题，如果可以的话，安妮。我只是在想，你知道，很多动物都会发出声音，但我们不称之为音乐。例如，有些人说鲸鱼发出的声音就是唱歌。所以更大的问题是，我的意思是，你谈到了节拍是内在的？那是唯一的东西吗？我的意思是，我们如何定义音乐？当我们听到它时，我们如何认出它？哦天哪，这是一个棘手的问题，因为音乐作为一种文化产品一直在不断变化。我的意思是，想想阿诺德·勋伯格（Arnold Schoenberg）的音乐，当它第一次首演时。有人
saying, that's not music, and now it's part of the canon, right? So music is an evolving cultural product. So what biologist study is what we call musicality, which is not the informal sense of just being good at music or, you know, having a lot of training in music. It's the really the building blocks of musical behavior, like the ability to keep time to a beat with your body or by singing the ability to very simple things, like the ability to hear a melody and be able to sing it back, you know, or to recognize it when it shifted up or down and pitch, things that seem so trivial and basic to us. It's only when we look at other species, we realize that's not so trivial and also in the brain.
说，那不是音乐，而现在它是经典的一部分了，对吧？所以音乐是一种不断演变的文化产品。因此，生物学家研究的是我们所谓的“音乐性”，这并不是指擅长音乐的非正式意义，或者你知道的，接受过很多音乐训练。它实际上是音乐行为的基石，比如用身体或通过唱歌保持节拍的能力，做一些非常简单的事情，比如听到旋律并能够把它唱出来的能力，或者当它的音高上下移动时能够认出它的能力，这些对我们来说似乎微不足道且基础的事情。只有当我们观察其他物种时，我们才意识到这并非微不足道，在大脑中也是如此。
So one example, songbirds who sing and people consider quite musical, they can learn to recognize a human melody perfectly well. You can take them in a lab and show that they will recognize when you play this melody. However, if you transpose that melody up or down, they just don't know what it is anymore. They don't recognize it. Whereas babies do that effortlessly all over the world. It's just part of how our brain works. And when you look in the brain, it turns out it's not simple. What's happening when we recognize it a transposed melody is not just the hearing centers of the brain.
举个例子，会唱歌并被认为很有音乐天赋的鸣禽，它们可以很好地学会识别人类的旋律。你可以在实验室里对它们进行测试，并证明当播放这个旋律时它们会认出它。然而，如果你把这个旋律向上或向下移调，它们就根本不知道那是什么了。它们认不出来了。而世界各地的婴儿毫不费力就能做到这一点。这只是我们大脑工作方式的一部分。当你观察大脑时，结果证明这并不简单。当我们认出一个移调的旋律时，发生的事情不仅涉及大脑的听觉中心，
is the hearing centers collaborating with distant other regions, including regions in the parietal cortex that are normally involved in visual spatial perception. So somehow evolution has wired up our brains to make this seemingly trivial aspect of music come very easily to us. It's only when we look at other species when we realize it's not that trivial. It's actually a sophisticated piece of cognition.
而是听觉中心与遥远的其他区域进行协作，包括通常参与视觉空间感知的顶叶皮层区域。因此，某种程度上，进化将我们的大脑连线，使得音乐这一看似微不足道的方面对我们来说变得非常容易。只有当我们观察其他物种时，我们才意识到这并非那么微不足道。这实际上是一项复杂的认知活动。
So what we study in biology is musicality, and also affect the ability to derive pleasure for music is a big area. And Robert Zetore, who's a big expert in that has a chapter in Renee's book, about all the brain circuitry that goes into this feeling of pleasure we get when we listen to music. And it's very complex. It's interesting from an evolutionary standpoint.
所以在生物学中，我们研究音乐性，同时情感（即从音乐中获得快乐的能力）也是一个很大的领域。罗伯特·泽托尔（Robert Zatorre）是这方面的专家，他在雷妮的书里写了一个章节，专门探讨当我们听音乐时产生这种愉悦感背后的整个大脑神经回路。这非常复杂，从进化的角度来看也很有趣。
Why all this complexity for this aspect of communication that we have? Is it there because we evolved it, because humans evolved to be musical? Annie, did you find that dogs, how long dogs can transpose or not yet? Yes, we actually are just analyzing that data now. And it looks like we've done a study to see if dogs change the average pitch of their howling when the music that they like to howl to is transposed up or down. And yeah, the results are in. And it looks like the ancient breed, we focus on dogs that are more closely related to wolves
为什么我们这种沟通方式会有如此多的复杂性？它是存在于那里是因为我们进化出了它，是因为人类进化成了有音乐感的生物吗？安妮，你发现狗狗能转调吗？或者说现在还不能？是的，我们实际上正在分析这些数据。看起来我们做了一项研究，看看当它们喜欢一起嚎叫的音乐向上或向下转调时，狗狗嚎叫的平均音高是否会发生变化。结果出来了，看起来古老的犬种——我们重点研究了与狼亲缘关系更近的狗——
because wolves are thought to shift their pitches when they howl with other wolves. They actually detune from each other to sound like a larger pack. So it seems like wolves evolved this ability for a functional reason to listen to what's happening with other voices and adjust their voice. And that's fundamental to human singing. but how did it evolve? And so we decided to see if dogs, which are related to wolves, can do this kind of tuning and detuning.
因为人们认为狼在和其他狼一起嚎叫时会改变音高。它们实际上会彼此消音，听起来像是一个更大的狼群。所以看起来狼类出于功能上的原因进化出了这种能力，即倾听其他声音发生的变化并调整自己的声音。这正是人类歌唱的基础。但它是如何进化的呢？所以我们决定看看与狼有亲缘关系的狗是否也能进行这种调谐和解调。
And it looks like ancient breed dogs actually do this. So it's kind of neat because it suggests this ability to change your voice pitch in relation to other voices may have emerged very early in human evolution long before we had the ability to imitate complex sounds because dogs and wolves are not complex vocal learners. They don't learn complex sounds by listening and imitating the way birds do. But they may have this ability to shift pitch. maybe that was one of the first steps towards learning how to imitate sounds and becoming a singing species.
看起来古老犬种的狗狗确实能做到这一点。这真的很酷，因为它表明这种根据其他声音改变你声音音高的能力，可能在人类演化非常早期的时候就已经出现了，远在我们具备模仿复杂声音的能力之前，因为狗和狼并不是复杂的声乐学习者。它们不像鸟类那样通过聆听和模仿来学习复杂的声音。但它们可能具备这种改变音高的能力。也许这正是学习如何模仿声音并成为一个会唱歌的物种的第一步。
Sess, that's fascinating. That's amazing. So, by the way, Ani gave me a way into all of this because even when I sat there and listened to the research on that first day in 2015, I still didn't understand why music was a point of reference or worth studying. And it was really when he presented on evolution that I got it, the bell went on. So that's why his chapter is so early in the book because I really wanted people to hear from him. He's also an amazingly articulate writer and speaker. So, Renee, what are your hopes for the future of the field?
塞斯，这太迷人了。太惊人了。顺便说一句，安妮为我打开了通往这一切的大门，因为甚至当我坐在那里听2015年第一天的研究时，我依然不明白为什么音乐是一个参考点或者值得去研究。直到他展示了进化论时我才真正明白，恍然大悟。所以他的章节在书里排得很靠前，因为我真的很想让大家听听他的分享。他也是一位极具表达力的作家和演讲者。那么，雷妮，你对这个领域未来的期望是什么？
Where would you like to see the study of music in mind in the next 10 or 15 years? Well, I just had this conversation with Francis Collins. And, you know, the first order of is to strengthen the research and to continue to build on what's there. And there are neurosurgeons who can perform, especially if they're doing, you know, complex seizure testing for epilepsy patients, that they can kind of test for other things while they're waiting and if patients agree. And so they're learning a lot about circuitry, about, you know, the predictive power of pitch and, and all this basic science requires real brain research. So it's not easy and it will take a long time.
你希望在未来10到15年里看到“音乐与心灵”的研究发展到什么程度？嗯，我刚刚和弗朗西斯·柯林斯（Francis Collins）进行过这样的对话。你知道，首要任务是加强研究，并在现有的基础之上继续发展。有些神经外科医生可以进行手术，特别是当他们为癫痫患者进行复杂的癫痫发作测试时，他们可以在等待的过程中顺便测试其他事情（如果患者同意的话）。因此，他们正在了解很多关于神经回路、音高的预测能力等方面的知识，所有这些基础科学都需要真正的脑部研究。所以这并不容易，而且需要很长时间。
But in the meantime, Dan Levitin suggests that there is a lot that works right now and we should be doing it right now. In fact, Julie Gerberting, the new head of the Foundation for the NIH, through a day and a half of lectures in December when we had another convening, our second convening, and she, in her off-the-cuff comments said, we have a moral imperative to be doing this right now because there's so much that already works. And when you think about PTSD and trauma and pain and so many things that people are suffering from, you know, chronic pain in particular, if there are things that work, then we need to kind of
但与此同时，丹·莱维廷（Dan Levitin）表示，现在有很多方法是切实可行的，我们现在就应该付诸实践。事实上，美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）基金会的新负责人朱莉·格伯丁（Julie Gerberting）在12月份我们举行另一次会议（我们的第二次会议）时，发表了为期一天半的演讲。她在即兴发言中说：“我们现在有道德责任去做这件事，因为已经有太多的方法被证明是有效的。”当你想到创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、心理创伤、疼痛以及人们正在遭受的如此多的痛苦时，特别是慢性疼痛，如果有切实可行的方法，那么我们需要将其
add them to the toolbox of what it is that people do. In the meantime, we're building the research so that we can actually make a case for embedding this financially in health care. Right now, it's mostly philanthropically supported. And Ani from your end, what are you working on? What are the next big questions that you hope to answer through your research? Yeah, so I'll tell you a couple. Before I started working on animals and music, my primary research was on the relationship between music and language in the brain.
加入人们应对问题的工具箱中。与此同时，我们正在建立研究基础，以便我们能够真正提出理由，将其在财务上纳入医疗保健体系。目前，它主要依靠慈善事业支持。安妮，从你的角度来看，你正在研究什么？你希望通过你的研究解答的下一个重大问题是什么？是的，那我讲几个。在我开始研究动物和音乐之前，我的主要研究是人类大脑中音乐与语言之间的关系。
That's what my book was about. And I'm still very interested in that, in particular in the question of how musical training can improve speech and language processing and potentially children with certain developmental language disorders. So I'm developed, I've worked on hypotheses about why musical training would benefit speech processing in the brain. A hypothesis called the opera hypothesis, which resonates so nicely with Renee's cult career, but I named it before I met you, Renee, but I'm glad it worked out that way. It's my favorite. About why musical training would benefit speech processing, and so I'm doing work along those lines. And also on the animal front, so we've made. So we've made a
这就是我的书所探讨的内容。我对此仍然非常感兴趣，特别是音乐训练如何能改善言语和语言处理，以及它对患有某些发育性语言障碍的儿童的潜在帮助。因此，我一直在研究并提出关于为什么音乐训练会对大脑的言语处理产生益处的假设。有一个假设叫做歌剧假设（opera hypothesis），它与雷妮的职业生涯有着极好的共鸣，不过我在遇到你之前就给它起好这个名字了，雷妮，但我很高兴它最后能这样巧合。这是我最喜欢的假设。关于为什么音乐训练会有利于言语处理，我正在沿着这些方向开展研究。在动物研究方面，我们也取得了进展。
move from studying just the fact that birds can move to beat to looking at in the lab at birds in their brain circuitry as they perceive rhythms because we think they might be a good animal model for this fundamental aspect of beat processing which is when we perceive beat even if we're not moving or intending to move we brain imaging shows there's strong activations in motor planning regions of our brain parts of our brain that normally plan movement and we think those areas are actually involved in predicting the timing of beats through simulated movement in the brain. But it's hard to study that at the level of circuits and cells, but if birds do something like this when they hear rhythms, even if they're not moving to the beat,
我们从研究鸟类能随节拍律动，转变为在实验室中研究鸟类在感知节奏时的大脑神经回路。因为我们认为它们可能是研究节拍处理这一基本方面的一个很好的动物模型：当我们感知节拍时，即使我们没有移动或打算移动，脑部成像也会显示我们大脑中负责运动规划的区域——那些通常规划运动的大脑区域——有很强的激活。我们认为这些区域实际上是通过大脑中的模拟运动来参与预测节拍时间的。但在电路和细胞层面上研究这一点很困难，但如果鸟类在听到节奏时也会做出类似的事情，即使它们没有跟着节拍移动，
if they're predicting the beat with their motor system, that would give us an animal model for how this works in the brain. And we could actually start to study this cross talk between the auditory and motor system and rhythm perception, which is really fundamental to why rhythm helps people with Parkinson's disease or other disorders. So I'm collaborating with a wonderful songbird neurobiologist at Tufts, Mimi Cow, Dr. Mimi Cow, in the biology department. And through NIH-supported work, we're looking at small songbirds and how they perceive rhythm as a way to look at the brain circuitry involved in how you predict the next beat and how the motor system is involved in that, hopefully illuminating things that will be of use for human clinical functions. Can you tell us about hummingbirds? I had no idea that hummingbirds also had rhythmic capabilities. Well, we don't know much about their rhythmic capabilities. The work that's been done on the rhythm and moving to the beat is with parrots.
如果它们在用运动系统预测节拍，这将为我们提供一个动物模型，来了解这在头脑中是如何运作的。我们实际上可以开始研究听觉与运动系统之间的这种双向交流以及节奏感知，这正是节奏为什么能帮助帕金森病或其他疾病患者的根本原因。因此，我正在与塔夫茨大学生物系的杰出鸣禽神经生物学家米米·考（Mimi Cow）博士合作。在NIH支持的工作中，我们正在观察小型鸣禽是如何感知节奏的，以此来研究预测下一个节拍以及运动系统如何参与其中的大脑神经回路，希望能为人类的临床应用带来启发。你能给我们讲讲蜂鸟吗？我完全不知道蜂鸟也具有节奏能力。
hummingbirds are vocal learners. They're one of the three groups of birds that learn to produce complex sounds. And most people don't know that because they sing these squeaky little high songs that we can barely hear. If you slow them down and bring them into the human range, they're quite wonderful. And so hummingbirds are vocal learners. There's only three groups of birds that listen and imitate. And that's how they acquire their songs, parrots, hummingbirds and songbirds. So, Renee, what's next for you?
嗯，我们对它们的节奏能力知之甚少。关于节奏和随节拍律动的研究目前是针对鹦鹉开展的。蜂鸟是声音学习者。它们是学会产生复杂声音的鸟类三大家族之一。大多数人并不知道这一点，因为它们唱的是那种我们几乎听不到的尖细的高音。如果你把它们的叫声放慢并带入人类的听觉范围内，它们其实非常奇妙。所以蜂鸟是声音学习者。只有三个鸟类群体通过聆听和模仿来学习，这就是它们习得鸣叫的方式：鹦鹉、蜂鸟和鸣禽。那么，雷妮，你接下来有什么计划？
How are you keeping this issue in the moment? minds of the public? I work also at LA Opera. We have LA County Arts and Health Week every year, and so we're moving policy forward in the state, I hope, and definitely kind of bringing people together in a lot of networking that's important. So let me talk about the Sound Health Network, which is based at UCSF, because there seemed to be a need, something that we talked about early in this process, for a resource center that people could go to, both the public and science, scientists and people doing research to see what everyone else is doing. And so they're not repeating because there was a lot of repetition.
你如何让公众持续关注这个议题？我也在洛杉矶歌剧院工作。我们每年都会举办“洛杉矶县艺术与健康周”，所以我希望我们能在州里推动政策的发展，当然也通过大量的社交活动将人们聚集在一起，这非常重要。让我谈谈总部设在加州大学旧金山分校（UCSF）的声音健康网络（Sound Health Network），因为似乎存在这样一种需求——我们在这一过程的早期讨论过——即建立一个资源中心，供公众、科学家以及从事研究的人员了解其他人都在做什么。这样他们就不会重复劳动，因为之前有太多的重复。
Everybody was siloed. The quality of the research wasn't necessarily high enough to be acceptable, certainly to an institution like the NIH. And then I created with the NIH a toolkit for research. So people are supposed to go to the NIH, especially if they're applying for NIH funding and see how to do it, how to submit a grant that has a chance of being acceptable. So that's been really important. So all of these initiatives will become stronger.
每个人都闭门造车。研究质量不一定足够高，无法被接受，尤其是对于NIH这样的机构而言。然后我和NIH共同创建了一个研究工具包。所以人们应该去NIH查阅，特别是如果他们正在申请NIH资助的话，看看如何去做，如何提交一份有机会被接受的资助申请。这非常重要。因此，所有这些倡议都将变得更加强大。
Now, the neural arts blueprint, I would suggest that people go to that website. They have a resource center that will open in September that is global. And as I said, it's much broader than just music. It's every aesthetic experience. And they're fascinating initiatives. I mean, there was a woman who presented with me in Savannah, Georgia, who said she's using VR in elder care facilities and invoking awe and transcendence. And imagine that you're stuck in a wheelchair
至于神经艺术蓝图（neural arts blueprint），我建议大家去看看那个网站。他们在9月份将开放一个全球性的资源中心。正如我所说，它的范围远不止音乐，而是涵盖了所有的审美体验。这些倡议非常迷人。例如，在佐治亚州萨凡纳与我一同发言的一位女性说，她在老年护理机构中使用VR（虚拟现实），唤起敬畏感和超越感。想象一下，你被困在轮椅上，
and you're stuck in a not very attractive space and you have that opportunity to get outside of yourself. Of course, it would invoke tremendous joy. So I said, so what are you showing them? What is in the VR? What's the content? She said, you're swimming with dolphins. I said, I would sign up for that.
被困在一个不太吸引人的空间里，而你却有机会超越自我。当然，这会唤起巨大的喜悦。所以我问她，你给他们看什么？VR里有什么？内容是什么？她说，你和海豚一起游泳。我说，我一定会报名参加。
So all of these initiatives have really had the chance of improving the quality of people's lives, and it's coming together and it's growing. Well, this has been a lovely conversation. I want to thank you both for joining me. It's been a real privilege to be able to talk to you both. Thank you. Real pleasure.
因此，所有这些举措都有真正改善人们生活质量的机会，它们正在汇聚并不断发展。嗯，这是一次非常愉快的对话。我要感谢你们两位加入我。能与你们两位于此交谈真的是一种荣幸。谢谢。非常荣幸。
Thanks so much. Thanks for having us. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices
非常感谢。谢谢你们邀请我们。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 以及您获取播客的任何平台上找到往期的《心理学访谈》（Speaking of Psychology）节目。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请给我们留下评价。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以通过电子邮件联系我们：speakingofpsychology@ APA.org。《心理学访谈》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢您收听美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。在拉尔夫超市（Ralphs）享受更多省钱方式，例如低价
in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
贯穿每一个货架。当您下载拉尔夫超市应用程序时，您每周都可以通过数字优惠券剪裁并节省更多。此外，您还可以赚取积分，在加油时每加仑节省高达1美元。在拉尔夫超市，您每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过省钱和奖励，每天都能轻松省下一大笔钱。拉尔夫超市南加州分店，服务超过150年。各州节省金额可能会有所不同。加油限制适用。详情请参见网站。本集目前尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。